and finally new rule the recent report
that informed us that in november of
this year the population of the earth
will hit 8 billion
is not good news
and those who regarded as such should be
treated for tick-tock brain
the secretary general of the united
nations of all people said that
welcoming our 8 billionth person was an
occasion to celebrate our diversity
yes what a comfort that people of all
races will be contributing to an already
unsustainable carbon footprint and
choking and starving equally
have you
have you seen what has been happening
with the climate in recent years did you
see england last week
england is pretty far north but the
runways are melting
our farmland is shrinking due to
scorching temperatures and drought one
out of four people on earth is food
insecure what we used to call hungry
there's another one
and billions face some form of water
scarcity
water isn't the only thing we're running
out of clean air
quality soil rain forests wetlands the
precious metals that make our phones
work we're even running out of sand
sand
which may not seem important but without
it you can't make concrete or glass like
for windows so you can look outside and
see the world ending
and
all of this is not unrelated to there
being ever more people on earth who tend
to use things
tracy stone manning is our director of
the bureau of land management and she
said if there were fewer of us we would
have less impact we must consume less
and more importantly we must breed fewer
consuming humans
yes i thought this was a duh
and until
until very recently
it was but now there's a growing
movement of people
more worried about population decline
decline that's what we should be
celebrating
but elon musk says
the biggest problem the world will face
in 20 years is population collapse
oh come on of all the excuses not to
wear a condom
[Applause]
population collapse
has he been to disney world on a
saturday
the only thing that's collapsing is the
dumbo ride under the weight of all those
obese eight-year-olds
[Applause]
i'm not worried about the population
collapsing i'm worried about the
glaciers collapsing in the food chain
and the electrical grid look i'm a big
musk fan
but i have no idea what he's talking
about when he says
earth could sustain many times its
current population and the ecosystem
would be fine
it's not fine
nature world news just reported an
unprecedented global extinction crisis
with more than a million species
expected to die off in the next few
decades the bees are all dying and the
coral reefs
fish populations in the ocean are
collapsing what the [ __ ] are these
people talking about
america's population is now about 335
million and there's a supposedly smart
guy named matthew iglesias who wrote a
book called one billion americans
arguing there should be a billion of us
a billion americans insert your own
traffic on the 405 joke here
[Applause]
his argument is basically that the
country with the most people has the
most power and that should be us and why
not we have plenty of space
okay
for the millionth time and let me repeat
for the thinking impaired
yes we do have space point conceded
it's not about space
it's about resources
didn't we just run out of baby formula
was the problem not enough babies
yes there's space on earth for more
people but somehow they all seem to want
to get on this train
[Laughter]
you can make a billion americans but
they're still not going to want to live
in north dakota
and
even if they did where are all these new
residents of the greater bismarck metro
area
going to eat soylent greece
the famous theory put forth in 1798
by thomas malthus that population grows
exponentially
but water and food do not
has not really changed we've improved
food growing yes
but it's still finite and you can't grow
water
the planet's resources are finite
but our predilection to always be down
to [ __ ] apparently is not
scientists say it would require almost
an entire other earth to produce the
resources we need to sustain the
population we have now it would take
five earths to support the population if
everyone consumed like the average
american which most of the world wants
to do to deny these facts makes you i
don't know some kind of a flat earther
of population science there just is no
there there to the argument that we can
keep adding people with no consequences
the argument as far as i can tell is the
same one people use for bitcoin
we haven't thought it through but who
cares
it seems like it'll be good for business
and business is affected by declining
birth rates japan is often cited as a
frightful harbinger of things to come in
other countries you see for some reason
some years ago in japan the men decided
to stop having sex and just masturbate
on the subway
the ensuing decline in birth rates was
routinely called a population crisis but
a it's not a crisis japan is doing fine
and b the crisis is really just one of
gdp growth yes a falling birth rate does
cause some problems because we need
fresh new participants entering the
workforce
to fund the retirements of the previous
generation of workers and yes if birth
rates decline too much and people keep
living longer the result is a society of
the aged and enfeebled or as it's known
today congress
but
isn't running out of water an even
bigger problem
finiteness as a concept has not been
repealed
we've forced upon ourselves an economic
model where businesses need ever more
customers but more customers
means more carbon more waste more
plastic in the ocean more mouths to feed
let's figure out a way to be happy
without always having to grow and grow
and grow and always keep growing why
don't we a [ __ ] alien on a spaceship
stop spawning people
climate activists shouldn't be chaining
themselves to trees
they should be blocking couples from
entering restaurants where they play the
violin
you